I didn't oh sorry about
that
yes all
right good
morning for the record I am Brandon
finny from straford 9 which is uh
Rochester Ward 6 uh I come before you
for
1582 um which just to allow the
consumption of alcohol and artist
performance areas um so back in 2017 I
came before this committee um to change
the statute and the labor statutes um
you know trying to to classify
entertainers in New Hampshire um where
previously they've been known as
employees of the venues that they' be
performing at which in reality they're
actually uh private contractors that
bill has been signed into law so the
issue now the reason for this bill today
um is because certain rules are still
being enforced and I wanted to codify in
the statute um to basically allow the
venues to come up with their own rules
as far as where alcohol is permitted to
be
consumed um and I I have talked to to
other venue owners um who have said that
the Liquor Commission coming in and you
know threatening with fines and and you
know the revocation of Licensing um I
think is a little um excessive for what
we're actually you know uh uh
talking about with uh this issue so I'm
essentially I'm just changing the
definition of what an approved area is
by saying that stage um or other
performance areas is a permitted area of
a building for alcohol consumption um I
actually have another venue owner here
who's going to come up to um um and
speak to you as well about this issue
but um I can't think of a single
incident since I've been playing the
music scene since I was 16 years old um
up until now
um you know currently where there's ever
been a problem with having a drink on
stage we are you know um to my knowledge
the only state in the country that
actually enforces this and u l
commission uh does not have the manpower
to to Really enforce such an erroneous
rule not really codified in the statute
so that was the reason for this bill
today
um uh you know it's not really that in
depth it's just really um you know you
know um just um improving you know the
definition of of what an actual approved
area for alcohol consumption is um I
just found it you know pretty arbitrary
to say that it's okay for one area of
the of the you know you know of um the
venue to say it's okay to buy alcohol
here but then you move to this area and
if you're performing at the venue that
you wouldn't be allowed to have that
drink I I've I've never run into an
issue where an artist is is you know too
intoxicated to perform or there's ever
been any any you know serious issue that
would need you know the the police to
come enforce this either so U I'm just
hoping that we can you know finally
squash this for you know once and for
all and and actually um you know allow
the music scene in New Hampshire to to
flourish so with that I'll take any
questions um I guess I'm I I remember
we've had this bill before so I'm TR to
remember what we did now how about the
Green Room can they drink in the in the
back room where they're waiting I would
assume so yes
yep what what is this statute what does
the current law say now that they can or
can't do well that's the thing it's it's
not actually in the statute it's a
Liquor Commission rule so what I'm doing
here is actually codifying in the
statute that it would be a legal thing
to have a drink on stage right it's not
actually in the statute so this must
been one of my great ideas to have the
department make a rule okay no you're
shaking your head okay okay all right
okay okay if I'm wrong I'm we'll we'll
just take it for for what it's worth
okay okay so all right any other
questions from the committee m MERS yes
representative bil just interested in in
uh knowing um where you perform some of
the you know me venues in in in the
state or that you've you know recognized
in the state there's been an issue yeah
my band has played in Manchester a
couple times uh we've never had a
problem with this we've never you know I
I'm well actually I'll I'll clarify that
someone from from the venue did try to
tell me that it was not allowed but I
tried to explain to him that I have this
law changed and so there has been some
confusion still with with who is aware
of these rules and laws actually you
know changing to allow things or not you
know things are still being enforced
when they shouldn't be so this is more
or less just a cleanup Bill to to to
actually say here's where the line is
you know essentially what I'd like to
see happen is the state kind of get out
of the way and you know and and allow
the owners to make up their own rules if
they want to enforce that that is their
prerogative It's just not you know not
allowing the state to come in and say
well we're going to find you th000 or
take your license away you know say you
know so that's what we're trying to
avoid well you say you want the owners
to make up their own rules that's a
problem too we you got to have you got
to have guard
rails okay so um the end of the day the
first issue was are the employees in in
saying that because we we do say that no
employee is allowed to drink right on
duty so that was the first kind of
hurdle to get through the second is that
as our our issue of always um underage
drinking correct so that in terms of
where whoever's you know in just because
you're in the band doesn't mean you
automatically get to drink no and those
rules are still enforced okay and so so
the the guard we do need to have guard
rails I agree that's all I'm saying yep
I agree
okay thank you very much thank you you
don't you guys don't have a card in but
you're going to tell us
where you are with this this bill which
I can't seem to find a copy of in my
file
here
okay good morning Deputy Chief Danielle
Elston for New Hampshire Liquor
enforcement for the record Mark
armaganian chief of liquor enforcement
licensing for the the commission
um we are neutral on this issue um and
and not opposed to it um but Danielle
will go over that and and thank you for
bringing this up and there we'll clean
up how this where this sits and and how
it can actually be enfor but we haven't
enforce this probably in 2 three years
um it's one of those rules that or laws
it is a law um that needs to be cleaned
up uh and at that at that juncture um or
at this juncture it's probably a good
time to do it so um uh Danielle's been
working on it so I'll leave it up to her
to to testify to the rest of
it good
morning um so the bill as proposed
doesn't actually authorize uh the
consumption on the stage or in the back
areas it would be suited better in
17927 which talks about the approved
areas of service um so that's one of the
technical issues with the bill as
proposes this actually just talks about
the definition doesn't actually give the
authorization to consume on the stage or
in the back are we don't and we don't
like law in definitions I agree
y but other than that if um there's so
so humor me so when we pass this other
issue before did you guys generate rules
based upon that passage of that
legislation there's two parts of this
bill you have the entertainers consuming
and then you have the approved areas of
service they're two separate things okay
so in the past when it was approved the
entertainers couldn't consume the entire
time that they were employed by the
venue when the def when we they changed
it the consumption was allowed when they
weren't performing so when they weren't
on stage because the stage was an
unapproved area at the time so they
could come off the stage during breaks
or before or after their performance and
consume
they couldn't bring the drinks on the
stage the stage was an unapproved area
under
17927 which says um no beverages or
liquor shall be served or consume in
foyers hallways kitchens restrooms or
other areas not approved for service by
the commission the stage used to be an
unapproved area it is no longer an
unapproved
area okay so you did that by rule that
the stage is approved we never it's not
in the statute you did that it used to
be rule it's no there is no stage in
rule so there was no law there is no
uh right so so that's what it's not
enforced now because the stage right but
you but the way the statute reads right
now says not approved for service by the
commission but if you never actually
said that that one way or the other
whether the stage was approved then this
is why some owners might correct this is
part of our
continuing rule reite that we're doing
we're going to fix this right yeah okay
okay but it has not been enforced like
the chief said in about two or three
years so right now we do have
entertainers consuming on stage but we
have you know we have so many law
binding liquor licenses out there they
they want to make sure that they don't
are non-compliant so the way they read
it they're a little concerned because
they so an easy solution to this is to
just add the stage to um as an under
17927 if we want to make it crystal
clear you can just identify the stage as
an approved area cuz this right just add
the sentence onto the end saying y the
stage area yeah and and ENT the the
cleanup in 2017 already authorizes the
entertainers to consume while they're
performing right and you also areas
designated for entertainers you know I.E
The Green Room we can add that sure okay
so we'll just take this sentence here
and lift it and put it into
17927 as
a new
sentence okay all right thank you very
much okay question oh I'm sorry I just
had a quick can you please repeat the
procedure so do we need this bill
amended or is the rule going to be
amended we are going to amend the
statute yes we will take this this
language and and instead when you'll
when you'll see when you when we have
the amendment it's a committee so there
will be take up it'll say um it will say
replace all because we're changing the
RSA okay is there also a rule change or
just the amendment evidently there is no
rule there is no rule change needed so
just the amendment okay thank you hard
to believe but we're ruless on this
issue not anymore we're working on it
working on the new rules okay does
everybody follow that then good all
right thank you very much anybody else
want to testify on this 1582 oh yes we
John
croan from
Manchester
right yeah you have to turn the mic on
yep you push it on and then you you got
to talk real close to it are you a
performer no you're an owner yes okay
sorry name about I feel like you're
announcing somebody to come on stage
ladies and
gentlemen um good morning my name is
John from uh Jewel music venue in
Manchester
um uh it's kind of sounds like everybody
wants the same thing here so that's
great news um I just add a couple of
points uh that I had mentioned um couple
of things that um about about the what
is or isn't the current situation ation
now it seems there some confusion um the
first thing it does is it kind of the
way I believe it to currently be not
allowing alcohol on stage kind of takes
away from uh our staff
resources uh it keeps uh takes their
focus away from other more important
things like one thing you mentioned
earlier was underage drinking uh also
sometimes you you may find people uh
sneaking alcohol in which is prohibited
so I'd rather focus our energy on those
more important things um and and leave
it up to the artists to choose whether
they want a drink on stage or not some
artists um like I am right now a little
anxious and nervous about you know
speaking public sometimes they might
need a drink to calm them down and uh
and when we get uh performers in
sometimes they're you know we're paying
them a lot of money $4,000 or more and
if a guy wants to go up on stage and
we're saying no you can't do that they
they don't understand it's a New
Hampshire law they think it's our policy
or that that we're targeting them
specifically so it kind of builds a
contentious Report with them it's like
no you can't do and what are we supposed
to do ultimately like arm wrestle them
bite them throw them out you know
so if if if this law continues to stay
the way it if it is still the way it is
um and we're threatened with a fine for
you know letting someone have a drink or
or not being able to argue with them
about having a drink you you understand
um so and then and then the other thing
I think probably the most important
thing is the state of New Hampshire and
the El commission actually uh you know
licenses us and trusts us to serve
hundreds and hundreds of people daily
nightly thousands of people over the
course of a year um but they're kind of
saying but not those guys up on stage
you know what I mean so I feel like if
we can be trusted to serve all those
other people and and do it by the law we
should be able to you know manage that
as well so I think I think that's kind
of all I really had to say there um
thank
you we do have a question if you want
represent buam live in Manchester
represent the west side where are you in
Manchester that's a funny question we
get a lot we're right on Canal Street on
Canal Street Canal Street down by where
they're building the big new uh 200 unit
complex right kind yeah down there like
deolis all right yeah and what type of
license do you have uh Ballroom license
Ballroom license you don't have deserve
food we do not correct and how many
people 500 and more 500 is our cap yeah
okay thank you
sure great yeah he plays there too
okay thank you very much it's yeah we're
downstairs from L&M same building
yes thank you so much guys all right
thank you anybody else want to speak on
this bill see none close the public
hearing
pit of a
place
okay why don't we
start and represent
playing
good morning and welcome to Commerce
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I come before you to present
HB 1151 this is an enabling bill that I
submitted after discussion with uh
liquor enforcement after I took one of
my many trips up to our offices for my
corporate uh life up in Quebec City uh
and it was a surprise to me after a long
day of work when I got back to the hotel
and I was eating dinner at the bar and
wrapped things up that the bartender
said to me would you like me to mix one
up for you to take to your room I said
wait you can do that here when I came
back to New Hampshire I called The
Liquor Commission and I asked him can we
do that here and they transferred me
over to liquor enforcement and I was
told no no you can't do that here so
this bill is an enabling bill it does
not require any hotel to do this uh I've
actually had discuss discussions with a
Matthew Culver and Aiden Moore at liquor
enforcement to try to make sure the
language was uh okay with them I also
talked with some people at the uh that
Lobby for the hotel industry and they
were okay with it because we're not
forcing them to do anything the language
of the bill says that uh hotels may
allow guests to carry a drink back from
the bar to the hotel room but it also uh
does not prohibit them from designated
in certain parts of the hotel is no
alcohol allowed and it prohibits a guest
from taking that drink outside to the
vehicle to drive to a different portion
of the hotel or or in any way do that um
so I hope that uh that you'll support me
with this and uh allow our guests to do
what I did which was form a bond with
their bartender over dinner and then
like to make sure that if I'm getting
another drink to go back to my room that
he gets the tip or she and it it's not
me going to my room deciding I want to
order a drink to come up to the room
paying extra for that and not knowing
who gets my
tip uh and with that I'll take any
questions U thank you um appreciate you
taking my question this seems to be a
little bit contradictory to another bill
and that other bill is for example let's
say I go to a restaurant with my wife
and we we ordered a bottle of wine and
we haven't finished the bottle of wine
which is unusual by the way but I I can
I can get that resealed and take the
entire contents of that bottle which
presumably would be more than one drink
so I always think that the same rule
should apply to the hotel that if I'm
having dinner there and I ordered a
bottle of wine I didn't finish it there
may be more than a single glass there um
but uh shouldn't I be able to take that
to my room so first of all let me say
that the difference there is that in the
hotel you are actually a resident of
those premises while you're a registered
guest there and this only applies to
registered guests you can't walk into
the hotel bar order a drink to go and
walk out with it um so that would apply
but if this passes and you are at the
hotel bar and you order a bottle of wine
you certainly should be able to
according to this take that bottle back
unsealed because you can take an open
bottle of beer a mixed drink a glass of
wine if this passes you'll be able to
take it from the bar to your room and
another thing I'll point out is I
limited the bill specifically to allow
one guest to bring one drink back to
their room so that you can't have a a
guest bringing a tray full of drinks
back to the room to supposedly give to
their other roommates but um you know
this this limits one drink one person
one room um and it's within the premises
they don't leave the
premises but would you believe the
answer to your question is both can have
happen so theoretically if someone was
sitting at the bar and or excuse me at
the restaurant table and only finished
half their wine and they want to take
that half bottle wine up to their room
or home the home is clear home is clear
that we allow you to do that but it's
got to be stapled it's got to have the
invoice on top of it and you got to put
it in the back of your car okay not
withstanding all those requirements that
if if you're in the restaurant and you
want to take it up to your
room your bill says one drink but in
your the with the reference to law
you're talking about we don't have any
requirements about where that bottle is
being taken right terms of going home so
you absolutely could then take that
bottle up to your
room but yes it would be in a in in a
plastic bag that sealed bag with the
invoice stable to it because there's
more than one drink in the bottle thank
you there more than one drink I would I
would believe that just a quick followup
what if the bottle was unopened then it
shouldn't be a problem or or still that
the law the law actually requires that
the bottle had to been consumed there
had have been some consumption okay now
could you go into a restaurant and buy a
bottle of wine and walk out with
it depends on the restaurant right if
they want to absolutely yeah you can
kind of overpriced don't you think y but
sometimes you don't but if you couldn't
hit the liquor stores closed that might
be and you didn't want to drive down to
the convenience store because they
wouldn't have that nice tasty wine that
that restaurant has then as long as
you're willing to pay that premium price
then you're set to take it out as it as
a take out like because it's
sealed because it's sealed okay
represent me give qu question for the
chair then on that on that topic um I I
know in Pittsburgh you can go into the
bar and buy a sixpack Pennsylvania is a
whole different world can we can we do
that here I've never tried it here can
you if the if the liquor store is closed
and you want a sixpack of beer for your
Sunday foot what he's referring to in
Pennsylvania is a controled state uh
similar to us um was that uh
Pennsylvania didn't have uh and they've
now since changed the law but they did
not allow convenience stores to sell
beer so if you wanted to buy a beer or a
bottle of wine you uh well it beer was
my favorite story my beer is you would
go to the local
distributor and the distributor would
still be open and he would sell you the
sixpack K it was always great because it
was a garage door and it' be one square
of a garage door and they' have the one
of those rollers and then you go and buy
the case of beer your case of beer would
roll out at nine o'clock at night you
could be buying a case of beer however
Pennsylvania did allow you to buy a
sixpack buy beer in the the bar at the
bar carry it out and and then carry it
out that was the only way I could find
yeah there is there is a limit to well I
don't even know if the limited statutory
but I think they're closed it was the
only way I could find a sixpack of Iron
City to watch the sealers on a on a
football game because on a in town city
is no longer it's I see light any so my
my actual question is represent play
thanks for bringing this up it's a
common sense bill on line seven could we
make it carry one drink per registered
guest in that guest's room I know you
said about not carrying a a rack of
drinks but what if your your other half
is upstairs I would I would say that's
you're bring dinner and drink that's a
fine amendment to me and if you were
going to do that I would say per
registered guest over
21 there you go all right very good
thanks because you don't want them
bringing back four because there's also
two kids in the
room but there
yeah it gets into the debate of
registered guests because usually
there's only one guest name even though
there could be multiple people I didn't
want to go there that's why I just made
it one person and I said if the wife
wants one she has to walk down and ask
for it
herself we'll have that discussion in
the in this
subcommittee thanks for taking my
question just a quick question cuz I
don't know this can you legally bring in
an unopened bottle of wine to a hotel
yes absolutely you can bring anything to
your room you want to so that makes no
sense not to do this this is basically
saying that the bar is allowed to let
you leave the bar area with a drink
because right now you can't do that yeah
so that's to so essentially this is an
enabling Bill allowing the hotel to say
you may leave the bar premises if you're
on your way to your room with the drink
that you got at our bar great thank you
yeah so and I and I'll um just for
discussion purpose so everybody knows we
actually had legislation uh I think it
was last year the before where we
broaden the circle from if you were
doing a wine tasting at a wine event
that you could walk out into The
Vineyards with that drink and we allow
the kind of the perimeters um in the old
days uh the original statute was that
you could not leave the bar area you
could not leave that physical space and
carry your drink anywhere um we got a
little looser with that when outdoor
facilities that now it wasn't it used to
be fenced in areas now it's uh we just
have strategic plants to Define that
area they not supposed to walk out so
over the years we're kind kind of
loosening up and trying to relax it but
at the end of the day it's supposed to
be the responsibility of the leny to be
responsible of where that liquor is and
who has it and and making sure they're
not a over consuming and B they're over
21 thank you very much thank you all
right who should we have first M you
want or you want to hear from the
commission good morning Mr chairman uh
Mike Summers president CEO New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association here
in support of the bill obviously this uh
does sound like a pretty Common Sense
solution um historically part of the
reason why you couldn't take your drink
out of the hotel restaurant and carry it
to your room is because it's about
approved areas right so the restaurant
is an approved area the hall the
elevator Etc are not normally approved
areas so um in talking to members of the
B of the industry um folks would love
this then they don't have to police it
um you know if they wanted to take a
drink to their room Etc um I thought it
was interesting your discussion about uh
to go if you recall during the pandemic
we the industry was empowered to uh do
some Togo we can still do that with an
additional license so your restaurant
license you would then get an additional
license for takeout or to go and so you
could then purchase six packs of beer
there are limits on what you can f buy
for Baron wine I think it's two bottles
of wine and uh yeah but the key element
not that I would interrupt you but the
key element was it had to be a contained
sealed bottle correct so it couldn't be
a pre-made gin and tonic for you correct
it has to be original manufactured
unless you had cutw G gen tonic that's
in a can rtds right um so so the what
this the flexibility in this bill it
allows for mixed drinks could then leave
the restaurant and provided they stayed
on the premises of the hotel so
obviously the industry think that thinks
that's a great idea um I will suggest
that uh if you love this idea you know
next year maybe we can take a look at
allowing mixed drinks to go
um with some sort of a ceiling
Arrangement but we'll save that for next
year over the commission's dead body
they won't allow that as you know that
they're not too crazy about that
suggestion so the question I would have
just and this is kind of posing for
everybody to think about um if someone
says okay I'm going to be taking it up
to my room and then gets uh on their way
up they stop by see an old friend in the
lobby the statue we're about to we're
working on is is that you were taking it
to your room would you be allowed to
consume it on your way uh what happens
if you stayed in that Lobby too long
what happens that or we can then clude
clude the lobby or the Halls being part
of the hotel
facility I don't want to answer for
obviously the experts in the room but my
sense of it would be that if you allow
this you've essentially allowed that the
entire footprint of the hotel is an now
approved area so I think that's the only
way the licensing structure works and so
I think at that point it would
essentially be okay so we need to be
care how we phrase that in terms of
taking it to the room we say is that
it's permitted now on the inside the
hotel
yeah yes and I but I think it is
probably okay to leave in the room as
the destination because I think if it's
uh just going into the hotel and
grabbing drinks and then bringing them
out to common area a hallway or wherever
it might the pool area for example I
don't know that hotels necessarily want
to be encouraging that per se but
certainly can appreciate that if a guest
has had a nice meal and has a couple of
glasses of wine left over on St makes
perfect sense yeah I'm just thinking out
loud because um I I can think of maybe
uh a reception where people where you
did choose to pull out a movable bar and
put it in the lobby and and therefore uh
that all of a sudden that has now become
a serving facility and in those cases I
would assume that they had already
gotten that as an approved extension of
their service area because it's still
you know delineated by a certain space I
think where it gets a bit weird and
sketchy is you know they're grabbing
drinks and they're going to the workout
room or to the business center or to you
know the pool area or something like
that I don't think the hotel is going to
I think that would that's a good
suggestion we want to make sure in the
amendment says improved service area add
that phrase y okay great any other
questions representative
yeah I just have a question about your
members is there a a a location or a
website um which indicates who the
members of the association are do you
have a list yes I think so um I know we
have it on our website I just don't
can't remember if it's behind a member
portal or not I don't recall but I think
yes I think it's on our website so that
okay so that can be obtained yes okay
thanks okay any other questions to the
committee members any none thank you
very much so much all right
Mark Chief you're
up good morning again committee members
Mr chairman Mark armaganian chief of
enforcement licensing for the Liquor
Commission division enforcement
licensing of course uh with me today is
uh deputy chief Danielle Elston valid
points that are being made through
through all of testimony um Danielle
again on this one has been working
specifically uh on that so she can
actually get into the Weeds on it uh but
at the same time no pun intended that's
this afternoon
right um but uh but yes um again this is
one of those things that has been
brought up instead of
to clean up things and we talk about
cleanups quite often in the last six
years that we've been together as a
group um with this Administration this
is going to be one of them also so I'll
leave it up to Danielle to testify to
the rest of it good morning um again the
location of the proposed language I
don't think is the appropriate location
this is another one that the language
would be better suited under
179 um 27 which talks about the approved
areas of service so just strictly moving
um the proposed language and whatever
amended language is agreed upon to um
17927 it would be better suited there
than in the actual Hotel
statute great thank
you oh
we represent pus thank you Mr chair um I
have
a question SLS
situation where I buy a bottle of wine
to take up to my room and uh can I take
it up to my room
sealed yes okay the second question is
if I have a little a glass of wine out
of it now can I still take it up to my
room
opened we well we just discussed
theoretically under current law right
now they would have to put it in a
plastic bag and so i' have to go all
through that rigma roll just to take the
bottle of wine off to my this could
clear it up if we were if you were to
limit not limit the one drink or the
registered guest then this would allow
you to do that so this would clean that
up well because the way it's written
right now it says one glass it could so
we could say one glass or a bottle or
bottle of wine and we do have several
hotels that actually also have
combination licenses which allow you to
buy the bottles or the sixpacks in the
lobby and bring those to your room thank
you so they have both an on premise and
an off- premise license
correct yeah that makes sense yeah we
have several how much is that it's part
of the combination conditional
license so so it's no discount you're
just buying the two license cor they
just they're allowed to coexist you're
just buying two okay no no deal okay R
Gibs thank you um just to be sure I
understood correctly uh so in in order
to um allow guests to bring uh a half
bottle of wine say which would be more
than one drink uh it would have to say
uh the revision to the statute would
have to say one drink or one open bottle
something like that correct thank
you yeah the the enforcement of bringing
alcohol into the hotel okay we do have a
statue to that says if you wanted to
bring wine to a restaurant a ly then you
um are supposed to require to bring it
like an hour before it has to be ahead
of the meal time but we do have an old
statue I assume that's still on the
books that do we take that off the books
that bring yeah okay so that one's gone
are you talking about the BYOB the boob
well no BYOB if the facility did not
have a liquor license where this issue
was if you had a liquor license
but somebody had this very special
bottle of wine and they wanted to use it
at the
restaurant then um we used to have a
statue that you had to bring in ahead of
time but you're saying that that's gone
so at this point in time anybody could
bring a wine I didn't think you could at
all I can't believe we repealed that you
can't bring outside alcohol into the
establishment you can't bring outside
but when we talk about a hotel room it's
really up to the hotel who will decide
whether they'll allow you to bring
alcohol and I've known I have some
hotels say may go way over the top to
make sure you know no you know no no
don't bring anything any booze to your
to the room because obviously they've
had problems in the
past thank you chairman that that's
basically called a corking Bill and a
lot of states have right it was we have
that well then I thought you just said
we didn't have it we have the corking
bill which is what you described from
the beginning which is to put it in a
plastic bag L that's corking okay the
question you're asking is do if someone
wanted to bring the wine into the
restaurant okay if it's a wine that they
did not buy at that restaurant to bring
it in I'm telling you there used to be
an old law and I'm now hearing that
somewhere along the line it got
repealed well I'm just saying there that
is a law in many states that you can
bring your own wine in and you just pay
a corking fee right we were one of the
first states to pass that role that was
that was Steve Avery St get back no we
have it it's just not called the corking
law We call we don't have a law that
allows you to bring your wine in we have
a law that allows you to buy the bring
wine in buy the bottle from the
restaurant the restaurant can cork it
and send you home so could you do me a
favor because I'm pretty sure we had
this statute on the books can you do a
little homework and
see why it got removed if it did get
removed removed at least find the
language and maybe we can put it back
in but it in my memory it it wasn't open
it was you would bring you're bringing
you know that you're bringing that
special wine that that you had and
you're bring it in because because the
restaurant didn't have it do you
remember this Mike yeah
do
right I think the
I thought there was an hour I thought
yeah so I'm I'm not crazy then so but
she do so am I uh I would say that when
it comes to uh liquor and fireworks
people make up their own laws he said oh
yeah there's a law against that there
really wasn't okay yeah the B BYOB is is
are restaurants that do not serve uh
liquor able to um ad that you can bring
in your own champagne like let's say for
Valentine's dinner that's fine y if they
don't have a liquor license they can do
a b do they need a license for that no
no oh jeez no no that's wide open vob is
wide open yes represent
spear
spear what did I say Gibbs Gib oh
sorry I'm shorter I'm the shorter
one seems to be a requirement in this
Committee of our
Democrats I'm I'm a little confused on
the uh and this is probably for my own
information I was in a restaurant this
past
summer and some friends of mine bought
in a bottle handed it to the head waiter
and said later on at dinner I would like
this bottle of wine and apparently they
had been doing
that
so that's not
allowed not currently no were they a li
or were they are they a licensed
establishment do they have a liquor
license oh yeah yeah okay so they bought
it from them or they bought it they
bought it from home and had been
bringing it in I think they thought that
they could because the establishment
said yeah okay and then we'll serve it
later and so I thought that was
perfectly okay no I will tell them Tech
Tech no but that's what we're we it used
to
be somehow somehow it disappeared
somewhere but we'll we'll find that baby
and get it so I would say that all of
this since it's all going to be in 179
that's put them all in one
Amendment okay that'd be great all right
thank you very much got one more card
left Mike
Summers you did okay really right I'm
sorry it's still sitting here right
that's right you this time you came
before that right okay all right that
we're all
said that's what happens when I shake
things up I forget how I shook it shake
and not stirred okay we'll close the
public hearing and we have five
minutes
okay
why are we
Whispering
okay
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
1591 and we'll hear from representative
pusc thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
introducing this for the chair uh HP
1591 FN relative to fines for prohibited
sales of
tobacco uh the bill moves fines for
tobacco rated violations from statute to
administrative rules adopted by The
Liquor
Commission uh has to do with RSA
126k and the people following me from
the commission and others will be able
to discuss this bill in depth great
thank you very much thank you all right
the chair will now call
on the
chief and we will be
discussing the amendment for this
bill
well the conceptual Amendment yeah this
is
up I probably could have taken the
morning off because Danielle's been
working on all three of these there you
go well um again for the record Mark
armaganian with the Liquor Commission
division forcement licensing with me
here today is Danielle Elman deputy
chief um Danielle has been working
working diligently on this along with
the other previous two bills so I'll
leave it up to her to testify to fair
enough good morning I guess maybe I need
you to fill out the three cards for
these two Bill these three bills sure
thank
you um so the the main purpose of this
bill is um there's a new product in the
market that is an alternative um it's a
synthetic nicotine so it's not a tobacco
product um it's just simply a synthetic
version of nicotine it's sold in a pouch
or um in a
e-liquid and the um both the licensing
statues and the youth access statues
don't account for this product to be a
regulated product so the intent of this
bill which you'll see with the
definitions of the alternative nicotine
product both put it putting them under
the license and in 126k allows it to be
a regulated product you have to have a
license to sell it and you have to be 21
to to possess it P or purchase it um
right now it falls in a loophole where
it doesn't really meet any of those
definitions so it it becomes an
unregulated product so that's the main
purpose of of um what you're going to
see another section of this bill that
you will see um is this is another bill
I testified to a bill last week where
the fines are in
statute um fines and
penalties um the I'm sorry the fines for
the licy are in statute so we are trying
to move the fines and penalties out of
Statute into rule so that when we
rewrite the rules we can rewrite the
fines and penalties altogether rather
than having to manipulate each statute
to account account for those so the
fines and P fines for the license
establishments and the penalties are not
changing we're just moving them out of
Statute putting them in the 600 rules
the 600 rules are being written right
now um they're in the first processes of
the jail car review so they are in there
as you see them in the statute we are
just moving them from statute to
rule and then um I know chairman hun you
want to about the amendment for the last
two paragraphs why don't you
explain um so the last two paragraphs um
this was initially put in to allow for
regulated Vape products to be sold in
the state um there was some unintended
consequences to the language as written
so I believe there is going to be a
Amendment submitted to this to um
further discuss the regulation of vape
and approved Vape products in the state
um that is you'll see the last um page
five uh paragraph six and then um
paragraph s you'll see um we do
encounter counterfeit and vape in the
State uh quite a bit so um this just
clarifies and gives us the authority to
deal with the counterfeit Vape as we
encounter it in the in the stores
okay um
yeah I have a question about the
ingredients of this artificial tobacco
is there um does it need to be labeled
what's in it
or um I don't believe it's a all the
packages that we're seeing right now are
they are packaged products it looks very
similar to a chewing tobacco it's sold
in a in a tin or or in a a vape
cartridge
but again it's a synthetic nicotine so
it's not a a a real nicotine it's a it's
a it's just a nicotine product so it's
not tobacco there's no it's not created
from that it's just a synthetic nicotine
that you suck
on so the what are the
ingredients is it listed on the
container yeah yeah you're saying
synthetic but what does that mean yeah
so it's a it's a it well some of it is
um we have whether natural or synthetic
so there's synthetic nicotine products
it's nicotine that's I guess handmade
manmade man-made nicotine and then
there's natural nicotine but they're
they're taking the tobacco part out of
it and just selling it as the nicotine
is
nicotine it's funny because I I read an
article about and they had a picture of
it they look like K Cups when in the Box
in the little shelves that Y and it's
supposed to be extremely addicting
because it's it's pure nicotine they've
been popular in um overseas for a while
and they they've made its way over here
okay representative spear you may have
answered it uh so this synthetic
nicotine is very addictive yes oh yeah
this is very addicting stuff
okay which uh then brings up the other
question we've been enforcing Delta 8
Delta 9 right right
now yes and how's that going um okay
they're um we're
encountering
um when we last year when we regulated
Delta 8 Delta 9 it was anything um
nothing over I believe it's 03 .3% right
um
we but there is not a lot of regulation
on the labeling and the the requirements
of the labeling also Banning the3 we are
finding Delta 8 and Delta 9 that's under
03 but it's not an age restricted
product so we are still having kids
purchasing Delta 8 Delta 9 um so that is
something that is a loophole in the law
right now so when we work up this
amendment I I'm a little concerned
because I know we did Sunset it and I'm
a little concerned whether we're going
to meet that sunset uh and regulate it
um so I I guess I would like to see an
amendment that will continue it and make
sure that again we're treating all these
products equally and that only only
licensed tobacco vaping uh facilities
could be selling that product okay and
and and as an age restricted product
yeah
okay I mean I I mean the the intent of
the sunset is um was to try to force the
Cannabis issue but that might not work
out so well this year so at this at
least that's that's legal let's Rel
Legalize It And but again allow only
those facilities to be able to sell it
okay anybody else have any other
questions for the
commission see none thank you very
much okay I have one card here and
uh uh breath Brett Brett Scott New
Hampshire vapers Association I
assume yeah you got to push the button
red is good my name is is Brett Scott
and the president of New Hampshire Vapor
Association as well as the owner and
president of smoker Haven and uh we
support this bill with the amendment and
ultimately look forward to working with
all of you uh for those changes so
that's all and how do you feel about
selling Delta 8 and Delta 9 I think it's
completely reasonable to have the age
limits um on the product and uh it
surprises me to hear that there are some
stores that are willing to sell it to
anyone that's under that age um as our
internal policies is to sell it only to
people 21 plus
good any other questions from the
committee members see none thank you
very much I have no more
cards oh we have cards
coming what a
surprise
kage you got a C separate card
okay so Nancy Von from the American
Heart
Association
and she is opposed to the
bill good morning um yes for the record
Nancy vaugh um government relations
director for the American Heart
Association um I have been wrestling
with this bill in the language in it um
I there's kind of conflicting thoughts
as to whether um this uh some of the
language in it is a good thing or not a
good thing so I'm coming to you opposed
only so that we can get on the record
that there are concerns and I would
really love to be um part of um any
process work sessions you know working
on this bill um the American Heart
Association strongly supports tobacco
retail licensure and um the uh my
initial concerns which I I think have
been allayed is to strike the fines out
of law before we see what's going to go
into administrative rules um but it
seems like it is the same uh structure
that's going to go into those admin ad
ministrative rules but concerns on that
um the other point which is not included
in this bill when you take out the fees
for the penalties for retailers but yet
in the bill um in statute I should say
um in 126k there is a provision for
penalizing the young people who are
accessing able to access these products
the whole point of tobacco retail
licensing is to put the onus on the
retailers to check for
um uh the age of of these purchasers um
we do not believe that we should put a
financial penalty on young people who
are being sold these products or getting
them even through other ways um that um
that really should be something that we
are are doing more of a an education
process or some other kind of um that's
not in place yet but it's the financial
penalties is not is not great in the
bill though there's actually another
line within that section of 126k to make
this a misdemeanor um so it's a
violation it's a misdemeanor for kids
who are caught with these products so
that's you know a big sticking point for
us in this um and we would like to see
some some work done on that section if
this this bill moves forward we would
love to see the penalty completely
stricken from statute and not put into
administrative rule that young people
are charged of financial um penalty for
for these products um and I just wanted
to make a point about the synthetic
nicotine so these it's not nicotine
derived from tobacco leaves it's created
in a lab but according the Food and Drug
Administration a couple of years ago put
synthetic nicotine underneath the ospice
of tobacco products so to say they're
not tobacco they're not derived from
tobacco but they are still considered a
tobacco product if they have synthetic
nicotine in them
um so this is an area where we do not
want to
see um something happen in state law
while the Food and Drug Administration
are working through the process of
deciding which products will they will
authorize to be marketed and sold um
there's still a lot of work to be done
on that at that that level um and the
state really doesn't have a lot of input
at this point on the Food and Drug
Administration process other than
regulating these products which I know
the Liquor Commission um tobacco
enforcement division is is working on so
I do have I'm a little confused you do
like that portion of the bill that we
are regulating those that nicotine that
fake or not nicotine product are you you
are happy we definitely want to see um
tobacco products whether they have real
um from tobacco or synthetic um the
other thing is the um the terminology of
alternative to um nicotine product is
again not actually a product
a name that is used by the Food and Drug
Administration so I'd hate to see it be
used as a car out or an exemption again
I don't know everything about this um
you know terminology and what its impact
would be it could be a good thing um but
I just want us to you know approach it
um in in conversation before just
passing the bill along well we don't do
that in Commerce we go to sub no no I
really enjoy the processes that um
chairman hunt that you you do in your
committee so very well thought out okay
thank you but I I will again you know so
our support or opposition might change
as we move along with this bill but I
will turn we'll leave it as there's some
parts you like and some parts some parts
I don't so General will just have to go
with the post for and thank you very
much any questions you do have a
question if you want to take a question
sure I
can yeah can you just clarify your
thinking on what your opposition is to
like they being a monetary fine or
penalty to somebody under 18 is it just
the idea of they're under 18 they
shouldn't be fined or it seems like that
might be a way to discourage use it it
there are some people who do believe it
is something that will discourage use
but actually there isn't an evidence
that really bears that out um but what
we have seen not in New Hampshire
necessarily I don't really think that
the Liquor Commission has has instituted
that policy but if this is being um
regulated by someone other than the the
liquor enforcement so local law
enforcement um school districts are
actually sending kids to court um being
that are caught with this and it's
usually the kids that really can't
afford um to have their their lives have
that kind of a a record on it's it
shouldn't be a criminal um consideration
for um to be caught with these products
the the industry does Market these
products to kids you know about the
flavors and and all of that that um so
there is a lot of marketing social media
pushing these products with young people
um and it is a a Gateway for getting a
whole new generation addicted to
nicotine and for the American Heart
Association nicotine is something that
that really can can cause um heart
disease or exacerbate um a a cardiac
condition that people have um so it
really does know what we have seen in
other places is that it is um sometimes
minorities um kids from lower income
families that are the ones most targeted
by these um penalties on
youth further question may inquire all
right that makes sense so when you say
and and just forgive me because I
literally am ignorant on this topic so
when it I definitely have the perception
that uh these vape pens are I guess more
ideal if someone's going to be smoking
something than smoking say a cigarette
itself is is there any truth to that or
is that just sort of uh what's is that
just the propaganda I'm hearing
so there still needs to be a lot of
study on these products as to what other
kind of constituents are inside the
product um so when you refer not you
when when it is referred to as an
alternative tobacco product the idea is
it's you know getting people you don't
don't smoke use these products instead
that's more of a marketing um but they
are not cessation tools it's not
something that will get people off of
tobacco and that's really what our uh my
organization's endgame goal is is to get
people off tobacco in
general thank you representative spear
I'm sorry for this do you have any more
handouts because we never made across
the room I do so I will pass that out
thank you yeah yeah just give them to
represent of grass thank you okay thank
you very much Kate fry from new
Futures in support of the
bill
hello I'm sorry I'm late and I got my um
note card but I couldn't find you um my
name is Kate fry I'm the vice president
of advocacy at new futures um I actually
am here in support of the bill it did
take me a little while to understand
what the bill did I do thank um The
Liquor Commission for pointing out um
some issues uh with that I had trouble
understanding and making some sense of
them uh first of all regarding the fines
um I do not have an issue of them being
removed from statute and put into
administrative role having worked in the
Department of Health and Human Services
that typically is where the fines live
it's just easier to manage to update so
I think as long as the promulgation of
the rules uh are parallel with the
statute and there's no um uh period of
not having anything then we should be
fine I did not understand what
alternative nicotine product was now I
do now understand that definition
nicotine is addictive we need to um make
sure these products are regulated um we
hear often that something like vaping or
maybe this type of product is safer CU
it's not tobacco but nicotine is equally
as
addictive I think of myself as well
educated in public health and I had two
College age daughters both addicted to
nicotine through vaping so it's
something we really have to be uh
serious about and make sure that we are
regulating um the last item um I
understand it may be moved to a
different bill but I do think it's
important to have a better understanding
of uh this in section 4 uh regarding the
pre-market tobacco product application
process um again I would just like to
understand it better if it is a tool to
make sure that products are safer out
there we have to we should look into
that um you've heard me testify on hemp
related uh Delta 9 Delta 8 products um
there are some serious products out
there that are not regulated and are
very dangerous so whatever we can do to
get close to safer products I'm
interested in watching the sub
commmittee work study committee's work
so I realized you were a little late but
I did suggest that we will put Delta 8
and Delta 9 in this bill and add it to
the regulation that was my understanding
and I think that makes sense yeah thank
thank you
okay thank you very
much anybody else would like to testify
on House Bill 1591 oh we got one more we
got to wrap
up really are we going to really charge
miners for misdemeanor no okay because I
remember there was some that's where
that's where exactly that was a Chin's
problem no just to clarify there's three
penalties in 126k right
now what's being moved out of Statute
into administrative rule is the
penalties against the licensed
establishment which is where all of our
administrative penalties live then
there's a penalty against the minor
which is a violation for each offense a
$100 fine and 20 hours of or 20 hours of
community service right or and or um an
education program then there is the
penalties for or the clerk who sells to
the minor which is a violation for a
first offense and a misdemeanor for a
second
offense so those are the three different
penalties in there so a minor cannot be
charged with a misdemeanor for
possession of Vape or tobacco products
oh right because because it was a Chin's
problem before about the memer so and I
remember it was skateboarding it was
something were that that so the word
misdemeanor will be removed it's just
simply a fine it's it's not in there at
all it's not in there it's only in there
pointing at the clerk or the owner of
the The Establishment not at at the
Juvenile the
juvenile what it's a violation $100 it's
a viol right it's not a misdemeanor it's
a violation and and you're hitting
exactly where I wanted to go with this
uh Mr chairman is the monetary fine
needs to be in there as a deterrent but
when you put Andor into it years ago
that gave us the latitude to deal with
this in an education point of view which
you know that's the platform for this
this Administration is to teach the
right way uh for compliance so we we
look at this as twofold there needs to
be a monetary deterrent but at the same
time the latitude to do exactly what was
test commity service absolutely okay
okay any other questions from the
community comme members
represent it's uh once again about the
synthetic uh tobacco um
we were just reading how it is very
addictive as addictive as heroin so if
someone um dies you know smoking too
much of this I mean what what happens
you drink it we eat it oh you eat it you
eat it yeah but if you
overdose it doesn't seem like it should
be even allowed to be sold but H who
determines
that regulated by the FDA so this point
yeah this point it's on the market so
now you jump into the argument of
whether or not nicotine needs to be
legal or not legal so it's it's one
level away from where we are today yeah
and that's are you as a legislative body
going to ban nicotine or are we just
going to age regulate it and that's
where we are today is the age regulator
okay thank
you actually a good question let's go
get okay every everybody all set thank
you very much having no more cards
nobody raising their hands and saying
they want to talk we will close the
public hearing on
e
okay sorry about my
delay uh and uh yes anyone can feel free
to stand so that means all the gentlemen
you want to make sure the ladies have a
have a
seat and am I sexist for that
yeah okay all you young youngsters make
sure you let the old geers have a
seat okay um so uh where we left off is
uh we asked represent Leon to uh work up
a new Amendment so I'll ask
representative Leon wherever she
is we have to
do oh I'm sorry
oh are on you need some time that would
work well okay all
right okay uh so is representative tur
do you you want to make a pitch for one
more time
for this is not a hearing you want to
just talk we talk about actually we
don't pitch I don't want to have too
much we I'll just engage you in the
conversation okay so where I'm I'm at
with this bill is that way I proceeded
it the idea that the Liquor Commission
was going to put pieces of paper in
everybody's bag was it was a
nonstarter and but at the end of the day
so we were trying to narrow it down I
mean new Futures posters in the stores
is really should be a no-brainer and I
don't I'm surprised we don't have them
already the commission would never have
a problem I'm sure taking those posters
so really the the where we're down to
now is
um the S slips right are we down to the
sales slips and that what we want to we
want to say something on the sales
slips okay um and I know that you
probably sent me the the the four
questions or something in terms of that
space um what I uh
my to be frank we had a bill in this
committee where we learned more than we
ever really wanted to know about the l
commission's o obligations to
fund drug prevention alcohol
prevention and and how we had a room
full of people tell us to not touch that
that that's
sacret and so where I'm inclined to do
is try to get the Liquor Commission do
what you would want them to do in terms
of having some space on the
slip to say what what um that I think
you had what four
questions yeah th those were examples uh
um uh Aiden Moore had asked me to sort
of just do a very quick mockup of what
it might look like I am not a graphic
designer so I very briefly took a a a
sales receipt picture from the internet
and pasted a very crude thing on it so
it was not meant to be a a product in
any way just a a an example yeah but an
example but it's uh but again in my mind
um anything we can do to educate people
about
988 is a big thing but you're saying
you're trying to be head of the curve of
988 98 is sort of like a last
resort well 988 is the referral resource
for uh people with uh alcohol use
disorder and many other substance uh use
issues so the 988 campaign and the
resource is much more broadly focused
the the the the production of those
posters are targeted at the general
public um as opposed to what this bill
was intended to do which was sort of
place this in the hands of the people
who are are coming in on everyone but on
a those particularly coming in on a
frequent basis to our Liquor Stores um
to both present a series of you know
scientifically developed questions that
are used to screen for alcohol use
disorder and I paired those down to um a
common set which is the four question
set there's others um and pair that with
if you answered yes to this call this
number and that's the idea behind um
behind pairing the questions with the
988 resource and and again I think
ideally both on the on the poster but
but mostly on the receipts I would say
is my is my main goal with that and I I
did speak to Jenny O Higgins at the
health and human services and she said
she developed those the content for
those posters um uh and I think new
Futures has produced them but um you
know she she greed and I think she may
have sent something saying that you know
that those are not exactly sort of the
right instrument in the long run but
she'd be more than happy to provide them
in in the short term good perfect so uh
in my mind we um this is reason we're
doing this is because this is an early
bill which means you would go to finance
and and then they're GNA have to come up
with some dollar amount or what this is
going to cost and I I I I to me that
that looks like an opportunity for the
finance committee to kill this bill and
and and lose this opportunity so my take
on this bill is to work with the
commission and get them to do
something okay and so therefore I my
take will be interim study but but be
before they get there I want to have the
commission to uh tell us how what
they're where they are and how we could
do something so that we don't have to
have legislation that would die that we
would get this to make it happen and we
would certainly have this bill uh we
inter room study we would have this bill
come next September we can see what they
did and see whether we accomplish our
goal or whether you know legislation
really has to has to happen so thank you
very much is there any other questions
that anybody would like to ask Kim
or B I think we're doing good all right
so thank you very much stay right here
so you can just you don't go far but
let's have the commission Chief are you
going to take
over good
afternoon Mr chairman committee members
uh I just got done mark armaganian from
Liquor Commission division of
enforcement licensing I just got done
talking to the uh chairman of the Liquor
Commission Joe Malika um we're gonna
we're going to take a left-hand turn on
this and and the way we're going to do
it is the chairman is actually proposing
to do a commercial that actually plays
on a f minute Loop in our
Stores um with partnering up with um
suppliers and Brokers so that the
message is continually only playing in
between the commercials that are
actually playing on product in the
stores um this is something that is
brand new in in the making right now but
he is figuring somewhere between 90 days
to 120 days to actually pull this off so
he's we're really excited about it it
wasn't something that we had been
dealing with in the last session but we
feel that this is the best way to get
out to all all the consumers and and the
public that visit our Stores um and and
to push the message forward that the
representative is looking to push
forward and and we agree um we think
it's a really good way to do it and and
I compliment the the chairman on uh
pulling on his uh network of of Brokers
and and suppliers to to actually pull
off this
endeavor so you're not crazy about
putting it on the on the invoices so we
spoke about that and and where that that
seems to be a very good idea and a cheap
um response to this at the end of the
day we see that people that take the
receipts after a transaction will nine
out of 10 times maybe less than that
crumple them up stick them in their
pockets or they will not take one at all
and and and being fiscally responsible
at at the lowest level at our consumer
level they're sitting there saying don't
waste the paper and and we appreciate
that in state business of course but at
the end of the day um knowing what we
know of our stores and the setup I'm
sorry that I have my back to you um
knowing the setup of the stores and the
amount of money that has been spent on
AV Equipment in the stores we believe
that this is a perfect way to push out
the message with professional uh with a
professional um uh entity that will make
this commercial at the same time using
professional actors um so that it's a
product that is indicative of the
product that the Liquor Commission puts
out every day of the
week okay representative
s so what if any cost would it be to
actually put I understand most people
maybe don't take the receipts but if
we're going to do it on receipt what
would that cost would it actually cost
anything or is it like does it really
matter I'm going to defer to Aiden
because Aiden did a lot of work with the
receipts good day my name is Zaden Moore
I'm a legal coordinator for the Liquor
Commission thank you for your question
representative I think what we found is
that um speaking to Mr Jim Richards who
directs the store operations that the
commission uses approximately a thousand
cases of receipt paper per year
and
to there is not enough room on the front
of a receipt to have a message print we
we can print one line that's what's
available on the front of a receipt if
we were to say utilize the back side of
the receipt for this
messaging um we would need to go out and
get an RFP go out to bid on it uh but we
estimate that it would be anywhere in
the vicinity of maybe 30 to $40,000 to
produce a receipt that has the
pre-printed message on the back that
would then run through the
registers
so are you saying you wouldn't be able
to change I don't know if this would
even be a cheaper option but are you
saying you wouldn't be able to change
the program to say all all the things
that I bought show up and then at the
end you know maybe there's an extra inch
or half an inch of space where it's like
you if you think you have do you show
these symptoms do you are you concerned
call this number whatever the message
might be are you saying that wouldn't be
something you could program in yes
that's correct on the front side so you
wouldn't be able to program that in we
could not we've we've talked to the IT
people the commission is in the process
of rolling out uh a new comprehensive
software package called NextGen MH uh in
checking with the the programmers and
the people who work on that project uh
we were told that we have room for a
single line on the bottom of a receipt
if it's going to be on the front now the
printers aren't capable of printing on
the back we just don't have that in the
software nor do we have the printers
that are capable of that so we would
have to go out and get paper pre-printed
to deliver the message on the back on
the back so you're saying that you
wouldn't be able to for the
questions this you can have a long young
so are you saying that like you you
wouldn't be able to do a I don't know it
seems to I don't know the it of it but
it seems to me like it would be possible
to like
have like a barcode you scan that has a
message and it's almost like you bought
another item and that's that's like a
default of everyone so if I have 20
items that I buy you now have 21 items
that are included in there and that 21
item is a little message that that the
representative would like to see on a
receipt well I think when the
representative and I have been talking
for the for a while on this I think the
idea is that his desire and I think you
heard him in his testimony indicat that
the message is a more comprehensive
message than what could be delivered in
a single line and and
therefore
um it couldn't be boiled down and
condensed in a way that would get the
consumer the information they're looking
for so he that's why when I asked him
when we spoke about what would you like
it to look like what what kind of
information do you want to see on it he
gave us an idea of what is that he
wanted including I think he mentioned
the four areas that uh person would uh
ask self analys you produ uh conduct a
self analysis to see whether or not they
have enough symptoms that they have
maybe possibly an alcohol use disorder
so therefore um we came up with an idea
well what would it cost to put it on the
back if we can't get you a comprehensive
message on the front what would we do to
get it on the back and that's where we
found out we use approximately a th000
cases a year and the cost to uh to
produce it would be up up in the range
of
$440,000 okay thank you thank you uh
representative Gibbs is next thank you
um about a week ago I bought one bottle
of wine in the state liquor store and I
took the receipt and when I got home I
looked at it and it was about that long
for one bottle of wine now I will be
honest with you that I did not read
everything that was on it but there was
an awful lot on it it was that long
isn't there anything on there that could
be taken out to make room for this
message to be printed automatically on
the front the way apparently an awful
lot of stuff is being printed
automatically on the front
now uh thank you representative I've
been told that no it could not be that
the messaging that's on the front is is
in fact what the
commission um utilizes to to summarize
the sale to give them additional
information about maybe programs that
are going on opportunities for different
sales things of that nature and that the
space available on the front with the
existing information that the commission
wants to put on to the receipt would be
just a small print small area on the
front or we have completely blank areas
on the back and we would have to tell us
specifically why what's on the front now
there's nothing that could I mean you
haven't
specified of what's on the front and why
it's all so essential why isn't there
anything that you could take
out well representative I I I I do not
know the answer to that question I I am
I ask the people who are
responsible uh for producing that and
they've indicated that the availability
on the front is one line does any my
suggestion is that perhaps anybody have
a receipt I mean I I usually have one
but I don't does anybody have have a
receipt in their pocket but my
suggestion is nobody in the room my
suggestion is that should be considered
um because what's what's on the receipt
is what the Liquor Commission decided
they want but they don't necess I mean
it's not the word from Mount Si it's
it's not all absolutely essential I
would say take a look at it and think
about
it I'll make sure that get communicated
representative thank you sen
Bros thank you for taking my question I
just want to understand the video
because I think you said it' be
manufacturers and then the message so is
it going to be drink our bottle at
tequila and then go to rehab well I I
think you when you look first of all
thank you for your question
representative um I think when we we
look at our signage it's a message board
right only it's a virtual message board
and with that virtual uh message board
there is a lot ofu stuff that might be
on it there might be a bottle um or two
that are actually being advertised on
that message board as that goes and and
uh to actually think about this in in
its purest sense as those bottles are
going through to have a message or a
commercial in the middle of that saying
if you if you have circum or you have
tripped um because we know good people
have tripped along the way we we deal
with that all the time um but but at the
end of the day it's probably a very
viable place for that message to be it'd
probably be a uh I don't know this is SE
in its infant stages right now I say a
minute or two message with professional
actors um with professional thought put
into it not us in winging it um
indicative of the brand um at the end of
the day there's a lot of time that has
been put into this brand from this
committee alone not only the employees
of the Liquor Commission and and the
chairman and Deputy Commissioner so uh
as we as we move forward if this is the
Endeavor that is is a viable Endeavor
that this committee would like us to go
forward with and this is something that
could replace I I really I know how I am
on on re I think the receipt idea is a
good idea I totally didn't think that
this was a viable solution last week
when we were here um in my my
conversation with the the chairman on
the way out the door he he threw that at
me to tell this committee that's what he
has proposed and that's what he wants to
do um I literally was uh my mouth my jaw
dropped I think that's very
benevolent um at the end of the day that
to know that our partners uh in the
industry are willing to walk with us
hand inand to pull something like this
off is is probably one of the the most
complimentary things that you could have
in this business that you know they they
they're acknowledging that something
needs to be done in this world to
message that out so um I know that was
the long way around to the answer to
your question but um I I think it is
appropriate where where it would be or
where his mindset is could it change
we just talked about this in the amount
of time that it took me to drive from
store Street to this building so uh
there's going to be a lot of forethought
put into this and there's going to be a
lot of uh um thought put into how this
concept could be um could be built um
with with the commission's input and IND
industry's input and let's not forget
the people that make the commercials
themselves they they're going to have
input so um it's it was exciting for me
to be quite honest about it uh when I
was told and and I I was actually
looking forward to pushing this message
to all of you um it doesn't happen often
so just quick followup okay follow up I
just want I I assume it would be a good
idea to have a phone number or something
where people could call absolutely well
the the 988 number would be at the end
of the day we want to be teaching 988
that's the it will incorporate all the
represent all the material that the
representative pushed forward that
should be on whatever it was a flyer a
receipt whatever it was this in that
information would be pushed to this
commercial okay representative spear has
another qu what yeah
okay thank you I I kind of think the
video is a good idea because it catches
people's eyes a lot more than what's
written on a receipt which we tend to
throw away so I think that part is good
and the payment for this the money that
it's going to take to invest in this is
going to be considerably more than
$440,000 so that's all going to be
covered by The Producers a NAA Grant so
through our uh National entity that
we're part of uh that we Grant get grant
funding with quite often on on
initiatives that we do whether it's
enforcement or the commission as a whole
um uh they are the basis for our
education platform um our driving
simulators all come from from
Napa okay so representative post did you
have your hand
up thank you very much um thank you for
being here today um with the virtual
boards are they in every liquor store
already and it can be used for this
commercial there's actually thank you
for your question representative there's
actually multiple uh let's call them
telit
monitors um I don't know the exact size
of them I think their 50 plus inch that
hang from the ceilings I know most of
the stores if not all of them that have
been updated to the
outlet uh model um have them in the Far
Corners and in the front of the
stores um they're hard to miss on the
second other side of it they get in the
way of my cameras also every once in a
while uh uh when we're looking at loss
prevention uh but it's placement that
they're they're there and they're very
prevalent in the in the
stores thank you
represent thank you just a question on
um the frequency of the video playing is
it a continuous loop or is it it's a
loop yes good question same is the same
video playing over and over again or
multiple yes so that would just jump
into the loop um the loop I think if the
if I remember what the chairman told me
5 to 10 minute Loop uh but it could have
happen as you know virtual it could
happen more often or less
frequently representative
Gibbs thank you uh what happens if you
apply for that nap to Grant but you
don't get the
grant uh we have our Napa Grant through
education is
yearly um we we put in for it we get it
so I don't great question representative
but I don't foresee that
occurring navka is a entity that like us
wants to get the message out there
especially in the world of education so
we look at this as an educational
Endeavor um and pushing it out is is not
going to be a
problem great thank you thank
you uh so representative tur I'll let
you have the last word
here
so that that was a left turn for sure um
in in my uh in my formulation of this
while I was trying to minimize things
the idea of a professionally shot video
never crossed my mind so um certainly
that sounds like it has great great
promise and I'm really excited to hear
that the chair
um chairman Malik um and the Liquor
Commission is is committed to to to the
concept um I two thoughts one is I I
would really hope in the mix of who's
going to produce that video that
DHHS um and the the the people at the
Bureau of drug and alcohol services are
integrally involved because they they
know the science of social messaging
that needs to be built in into that that
video so that was one thought um and uh
you know I I ju Just just my one last
pitch for you know both rather than
either um you know the the value of the
receipts I agree most of them will be
thrown away um the thing about receipts
is they go home with a lot of people
even if they go home in in you know the
bottom of a bag or or crumpled up
foreman and it's not just the consumer
that we're trying to reach it's their
family it's their friends it's somebody
that would see those questions and say
hey these sound like you maybe you
should think about this um so that that
was it and I'll just I'll just say again
whether this goes forward in a in a
legislative way or not a legislative way
um I'm I'm in happy to hear it it it's
going to go forward um I I will just
point out the last the last line of the
amendment which which was originally um
part of the bill um it says the content
developed under this paragraph may also
be reformatted and distributed by The
Liquor Commission via any other print
signage and or El ronic means and to any
other group of recipients that the
commission may deem appropriate and that
was something that actually came out of
a a discussion with Aiden Moore and I
while we were um considering this as an
LSR that that if the content were
developed it would be good to go on a
website it would be good to go on a you
know uh to other PE other groups that
might want it even if if they weren't
the liquor commissions and and like I
said not not never crossed my mind that
one of those elic formats could be a
video so um that's that's my okay great
thank you all right um any discussion
from the subcommittee members and I'll
remind everybody who's on it pusk Walsh
hunt post burrow
Sullivan buo and spear is a repl buo is
in
spear no
vent no beer is replacing vinent
okay any discussion from the
subcommittee members I just want to
okay I commend The Liquor Commission I'm
a co-sponsor of this bill and uh I think
that's the way to go I think you know
putting it on the um uh receipt the uh
receipt that we get from the cashier I
think it's going to be pretty much
useless so I think this is huge and uh I
appreciate the uh effort
from the commission great all right so
representative bullo second by
representative pus moves interim
study any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
say
I those
opposed so moved unanimously here's the
list okay uh before I move on since I
have a room full of canopis
people stay tuned for this one you will
see it on your legislation
someday if they if we end up going
Cannabis stores if we end up doing this
model we just then we'll end up asking
them to
also run this
ad
She's Too Tall okay I will close that
subcommittee and we'll now move on to
our last
subcommittee okay so
now I think we gave you plenty of time
there huh yes you did thank
you I would have sent this out earlier
however I was just making sure all of
the changes that I wanted wanted to make
sure we're in this amendment we're in
fact there and I needed to look at it so
I could tell you which page so you
weren't flipping through with me um so
last week one of the biggest and sort of
biggest most surprising conversations
was on the data collection uh because we
had some friends from the Department of
Safety who found out that they were
involved in this process for years and
years but had not been made aware
because this is a massive Bill the
Department of Health and Human Services
led by Mike Hol looked at it looked at
the possibilities and gave us language
if you turn to page 30 so I'll give you
a minute to flip
there it'll be down towards the bottom
lines 27 through
36 I'll wait till I don't hear the paper
flipping so that I can read along so
everybody can
hear okay so we see that Department of
Health and Human Services shall yes so
now it's not later than two years after
the effective date of this chapter and
every two years thereafter the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall wear a appropriate enter into
memorandums of understanding with the
Department of Safety the Department of
Justice the Department of Education the
commission and any other agency
determined by the Department of Health
and Human Services to possess relevant
data to collect data and produce and
publish a report that includes Baseline
data and the most current data regarding
the Health and Welfare outcomes before
and after cannibis legalization and
regulation for adult use all the DAT all
data in the report shall be
non-identifiable and respectful of
personal privacy this report may be
combined with the report um that's
otherwise required for substance use
prevention treatment and Recovery um
that is allocated through one of the
funds established in this um it also has
some Appropriations and some other
language in order to actually enable it
so those amendments are in here but I
don't think I need to point you to page
37 for that um with that I guess I guess
my question would be if you want to wait
and see if there's any questions for my
cult or if that seems that that would be
a good way to move forward on that
language sounds good then let's keep on
rolling
and I'm sorry I'm an economist I make
bad puns I
apologize um so we'll move to public
consumption on page
seven um there's been a very big push to
make sure that um at some point there is
more than just a violation for public
smoking um so the language that has been
floated by just about everybody would be
that after the third um a third or
additional time and having two prior
convictions within the 5 years of the
third or subsequent offense that it' be
guilty of a misdemeanor um I didn't see
that they left out that it should be a
Class B misdemeanor because I think it
would make sense to not have jail time
on it um maybe if you want to add
another enhancement but at a certain
point at a certain point when we have PR
bail and everything else how much do we
need to be pushing that we need to make
sure we have the sledgehammer but we
also need to not build in a huge
bureaucracy that's going to be more than
we need and that's something that we'll
have time to work on if we see that
there are repeat offenders getting
multiple Class B misdemeanors that'd be
a good reason to have another law to
further strengthen it but I think at
this point um hopefully that goes far
enough for everybody involved for those
penalties without going too far for the
civil liberties folks and the good news
that won't come to this committee
correct correct so even a better reason
to pass that one off
sorry um okay and then now we get to The
Possession limits um been the concern
raised it's on page 34 so this is around
the annulment and um throughout it it
had a bunch of language about about
annulling based on The Possession limit
so adding into the definition of
possession limit that it's the current
possession limit as defined in the
definitions of the bill um I think it's
a good way to make sure that it's
there's no malicious compliance I don't
expect that of anybody today but let's
do the belt and suspenders and make sure
our language is clear and then um one of
the last issues and actually is probably
one of the underpinning issues about how
we're trying to figure this out whether
it is these um retail outlets or a
franchise model the whole point is to
make sure that the government is not
picking and choosing who's going to make
a fortune in this that is our biggest
concern and that's why some of our
friends are coming at this and looking
at it as a franchise model in order to
limit that opportunity right now I don't
think their language sufficent I meets
those limits and makes sure that
somebody's not going to be able to build
a huge fortune and then build a mode
around it um and the limit on 15 stores
quite frankly creates a lot of that
incentive um the question is when would
it make sense to increase the number of
stores if you turn to page
12 that is the section that talks about
the number of stores that we would have
and um that would add when they
determine whether to increase the number
of cannabis retail outlets and if so by
how many one of the goals would be
licensing sufficient cannabis Outlets to
avoid a second secondary market for the
transfer or sale of cannabis retail
outlet licenses one such indicator of a
secondary Market would be an increase in
the intrinsic market value of a cannabis
retail outlet beyond the premium
reasonably attributed to eliminating the
time and compliance steps required to
obtain
ler fortunately this is a committee I
actually can say that in front of
because you're Commerce and you deal
with economic issues uh the question
would be if there's other ways to um to
figure out how we're going to make sure
that we're not building an OT around
somebody's highly profitable exchange um
now that we've gotten closer to the wire
I've had some more discussions with
people involved in this and there may be
a way where we can get we can have more
people that aren't walking away sad when
we come from our discussion so I'd
actually like to be able to have a
little bit more time to see if we can
get even more people onard board I know
that right now this has some pretty
broad support but let's see how much
broader we can build the support so I
think that we might be able to do that
and find a way to make sure that we are
not handing people a pile of cash with
the state stamp on it while also
protecting people making sure that the
appropriate regulation is there this
bill as amended already meets all except
one of the governor's requirements and
the one it doesn't meet is the
restriction on the lobbying and campaign
donations a lot of that is around I
believe is around the fear that we could
be creating a castle full of money with
a mode around it and if we're able to
figure out how to not do that and to
structure this in a way where we're not
picking the winners then that becomes
less necessary um as I reviewed a draft
from some you know people on the other
side the other body um they also didn't
have that language on the lobbying and
campaign contributions when I saw the
most recent version so this is an idea
where we're all just trying to make sure
that that we're not picking winners and
losers here um and one of the other
things that I would note is that as I
was reviewing I've been trying to meet
with the governor I've been going by his
office every day I want to know where
his mind is at on this because you guys
have been working on this diligently for
years and years and years and I'm
hopeful that we can finally get to
something that passes and has as few
people sad and as many people happy as
possible when we finally get there so
I'm hoping to speak to him but in the
absence of that I searched for any of
his comments and the only thing I could
find on him talking about a franchise
model was he said that he'd consider a
franchise model but the details matter
and quite frankly I agree the details
are what matter and um that's why I'm
hopeful I can keep working on this if he
can give me another week I think we've
gone pretty far from where we
started okay representative Herbert has
a question um wouldn't it be
truthful that uh out absent a franchise
model which is a private one that uh the
issue of uh uh donations and political
donations etc etc etc are pretty much uh
non non-event because the state is
getting the has the stores and uh are is
doing the business as as is the case
today um quite frankly thank you for the
question I actually struggle finding any
constitutional way to limit that the
lobbying and the Contra the campaign
contributions um I think it's more just
an indication of the symptom um and I
figure if we can get to the underly it's
more of a symptom if we can get to the
underlying disease about picking winners
and losers then it becomes a mood issue
but I agree um that I agree that moving
to private business that that becomes
less of an issue as moving to a moving
back to a liquor store model would also
remove that because state employees and
state agencies can testify on on
anything it's part of their right of
free speech so it gets into that weird
gray area with franchises which is yet
another one of the reasons why I want to
make sure we're in really really
cautious if we end up down that path so
thank
you yes representative San so see the
language here we've talked about this as
you know so I'm just curious what made
you not want to put in like a firm
number that would be approved
I
mean I don't get it so my concern with
having a fir firm number that's the
Baseline to be approved is that that
also then may be seen as um something
that they're not going to go beyond so
if you had three more stores every three
years but the market actually suggested
you should have three every year if you
have somebody that as a regulator is
trying to be more conservative about how
it's rolled off out or more cautious as
it's rolled out they may take that three
instead of three or more to heart so
that's why why I'm concerned about
basically you know it's anchoring so if
you say that it would be three but let's
say our market clearing it would be
similar to Lakers stores with 65 to 67
stores if there's an anchoring to the
idea of only having three every three
years or five every year whatever number
it is I'm afraid that that'll anchor the
decisions as opposed to having a more
holistic look at it so what would be the
process for for like I know you don't
Define it in here but what if you could
Define it how would you define what the
proc processes to decide what the market
looks like so if three is too small it
probably is if we're starting with 15 it
would take us forever to get to whatever
the liquor numbers are probably we need
to go beyond that I'm guessing just
because they're going to be smaller type
stores but what would what would be the
process that you would see playing out
if you were in charge of Designing it I
know you're not I know the build doesn't
do that but I just want to hear what
you're thinking on it well so when you
look at it you're going to look at the
model of the retail outlet if the retail
outlet were to be more more of you know
a Costco where they're Distributing with
low margins and keeping overhead low um
that they have a specific process that
they're going through they have a
certain amount of understood costs and
um and they're they're passing it
through at a very low markup then
there's not as much profit in those
stores so you're going to get an idea
based on sales traffic and the volume
looking to see if it see how it's going
you'd also look to see if it seems that
we have pulled the New Hampshire Market
back into new Hampshire as opposed to
having continue people continue to cross
the border I mean when you look at the B
border towns choosing between a Market
Basket in Massachusetts in New Hampshire
is less of a big deal um although
there's some of the tax issue but
sometimes you get a greater selection in
Massachusetts and it would be higher
taxed in other states but I you'd want
to make sure that um you're looking at
all these aspects if you have one where
they where there's U no no nothing to
set what they're Char charging nothing
to set what's going on in this
government created Monopoly if you have
no limits on it and they're charging a
huge markup because they're the only
only store in town then that would be
another indicator that we would need to
have more stores the other one would be
the one that's laid out here saying that
um saying that basically if these are
going at an extra premium I mean you
have taxi medallions in New York City
where they're trading at a huge premium
and literally you've invested in your
retirement because when you're done you
sell it to somebody else and now you
don't need to make the money because
that intrinsic value of The Limited
scarce scarce taxi Medallion is your
value so we want to make sure we're
avoiding it so this language only
prevents the taxi Medallion issue and so
that's why digging into the idea of
trying to make sure it's attractive
enough for people to participate but in
a capitated market where there's only 15
stores you would need to have more
constraints on it so that you're not
building up your money castle with your
moat and swimming in it like Scrooge
McDuck um and I think that that's why I
would would like to be able to take a
look at it and now that I can better
understand some of where the proponents
of the franchise model are coming from
and what they think that their model
will do not what I see on paper with
their model but what they think it'll do
we may be able to find some way where
where it'll be easier to find a market
clearing price but that's a problem with
controlling anything that should be free
market right none of us know how to
determine that but um we can also look
at the factors do you
think I mean it's hard to do and it
could be almost like a shell game but do
you think
having
non-transferable uh licenses or the
we'll just call it medallion for the
sake of that so we have Medallion um
it's it's tied to me if I open up the
store and then if I somehow I'm not
involved in that business I know there
are loopholes there are loopholes what
I'm saying is creating loopholes but I'm
say do you think that would be in any
way effective to to prevent to prevent
the rent seeking that's going to come
from from medallions The Medallion
system that we're essentially creating
well I think a lot of it's looking at
how different different different uh
businesses have done this if you look at
Chick-fil-A um you're an operator not a
franchisee when you're at Chick-fil-A so
you can make you make a certain amount
at Chick-fil-A you'll make about
$200,000 operating a store but you don't
have transfer rights to that so you
can't transfer that to anybody else so
it's it's one of those that's a more
accessible franchise because you don't
really need much money down
but you're able to operate it here we
wouldn't want the state building out the
stores so you need to look at the the
whole angle and you need to look at the
process but in order to allow for the um
Capital needs and Capital Improvements
and the operational costs there's going
to have to be some balance in it but you
also need to make sure that that when
you're setting this up you know you're
not creating that rent syncing you're
not creating these sorry we're getting
into econ talk because it's economists
talking here but it's it's really
crucial to make sure that what we set up
you maybe it's a matter of Manufacturers
Su suggested the state state markup some
way that we can have it so that it
doesn't get out of hand and that once we
know what market clearing is we can pull
back those proxies for the free market
because if we end up having whatever the
right number of stores is then you don't
need to have those limits on it and it
would be inappropriate to keep a certain
markup to be the Costco where you have
8% off after costs so how how how would
we inval uh if we're going to allow
transfer that means so so you're saying
right now you are a proponent of
transfer of
licenses I I'm saying it all depends how
the whole cake is baked um it's just
it's it's a very complex issue and I
don't want to lock myself in one way or
the other I'll be locked in by next week
on what I do but um knowing that there's
a little bit more time and I have more
of the understanding of what the
proponents of the franchise model are
trying to achieve we may be able to
reach something that works right and
then in terms of like who will be in
charge of so you kind of laid out what
you would do if you were in charge of
this we'll call it a board that reviews
every few years whether or not the what
the market clearing rate should be
um is that just going to be in rule
making we're going to decide who's on it
is that g to be in rule I mean should
should we have some language in that
excludes any current
operators uh I mean I'm I'm just I don't
really know I haven't thought about it
until right now but I'm just thinking
about uh you know the previous language
we had spoke about where it's no less
than some number then you know that
there's some guaranteed amount but there
was still some sort of board involved
but I I never really thought too much
about the board because the number was
built in which gave me some comfort so
what is this process for coming up with
the board I mean should that be spelled
out here because Ru making feels like
that's a potential opportunity for the
industry to capture um with the
structure of that um so that actually
brings up a really good point because
the general cannabis Advisory Board
should have those people who are
involved in it as well because some of
this process you want to make sure that
people involved in the industry can help
have an but if you had the Cannabis
transfer Advisory Board I know the last
thing you want is more boards but if you
had a group of people who could be the
ones that made an assessment um looking
at people who were involved in business
looking I can talk with you and try and
figure out who might be able to get a
better look at what would help
facilitate Market um but I think the
idea of potentially making that separate
or a designated subset of the canid VIS
Advisory Board um has a lot of Promise
because you're right if you're advising
on one topic you're not necessarily the
right people to advise on the other yeah
and I'm I'm sympathetic to the anchoring
idea and I'm curious to see where this
goes and happy to work with you offline
but I think this language does
not this language doesn't really
Safeguard against
medallions being created as of right now
I I think the language of it is great
but like the devil is always in the
details and I think the detail that
needs to be fleshed out is are the
people who are going to be owning these
licenses going to be involved in the
process of deciding whether not they
want to approve more competition or not
like that's fundamentally what we're
talking about here is I own a business
are you going to ask me if I want
competition I'm always going to say no
and if they're somehow involved in that
process or they're not even at Arms
lengths you know like like it
that's why I get nervous about not
having the the number that would anchor
which is a very fair concern but um that
is I know you understand what I'm saying
I I know you know where I'm going with
this so well and the other issue with
that too is that you're right until
there's actually an offer until somebody
is offering one of these for sale you
can't see if there is a premium because
if all 15 um under this model um I think
we have that you can own three I'm not
sure there's I some of the details I I
my eyes are glazing over between the
different models I've I've seen one of
the franchise that's limiting to three
of the fac of the retail outlets another
that's limiting somebody to five so if
you had that and you had three different
Market groups that each had five when
are they going to put something on the
market if they already have a good thing
going so you're right you wouldn't have
that transparency if there's nothing
actually offered for sale so this was an
attempt to move towards that that's why
trying to figure out and give me another
week would be helpful but I love having
these um ideas brought out in the open
because these are the things that
everybody's been grappling with because
the state the pure state run model
avoids those but then you have the plant
touching issue the franchise model
depending on how it's set up if you have
a heavy enough hand and there's really
no profit to be made in the stores then
it's somebody who just wants to operate
a store because they just want to run
run the local operation but there's not
much upside to them then again why would
they invest in the store if there's not
enough upside to cover that you move to
an agency one and then that's why we're
trying to figure out about the transfer
price and if you had free market we
wouldn't have to be here but that won't
get signed into law so all right thanks
that's the hand we're dealt okay so you
know who you need to talk to this week
to I've talking on that yes we'll
continue talking okay representa buo
thank you for taking my question I have
a
concern with cassino owners owning a
cannabis outlet and I don't know if
there's you know
I have many reasons but um it probably
can't be included in this bill I don't
want to jeopardize this bill but I just
want everybody in this room to know that
I do not think a casino owner should own
a cannabis
store thanks no sin
corporations okay represent
spear thank you this is a question gared
towards uh you rep represent ative hunt
chairman
hunt last night at some point you sent
us out another yet another
amendment what was the purpose of
that uh and it's one we've seen before
and really
hate why did you send it uh because
Senator abbis asked me
to are we supposed to do anything with
it uh it's a purely a discussion point
but I would
say um you never know what happens on
the Senate side don't
know okay yes
W uh there was a a commission a cannabis
commission over the summer and I believe
you correct do we have a copy of that so
that what you got from Senator abbis
last night oh okay for all Ted purposes
he was the chairman of the commission
okay and in that was a question about
you the atc's and every everything you
ever wanted to know about the commission
has been been explained and that would
be if if there was a commission report
that's
it so there there was no official
commission report that is correct okay
thank
you representative Bros he this may be a
loaded question but how to put this
politically correct way um why does a
certain Senator want to blow up what has
been worked on by you know infinite
number of people and have come to
something that seems like it's 99% of
what the governor wants why is there a
desire to blow this up at this date
thank
you would you
believe would
you at any rate he's
everybody's entitled to their opinion
and that was his
opinion okay so I hear a request to uh
postpone taking action on this bill for
another week and uh I will grant that
and so I will schedule another
subcommittee uh for next
Tuesday and I'll give it to Wednesday to
execute so that way we it we whatever
happens it you'll give a day to get it
in get it in and get Amendment a proper
Amendment drawn up thank you um I'm
we're going to be executing a bill at
9:30 in my committee on Wednesday the
14th so wednes after that Wednesday
afternoon would work for you it does
okay perfect thank you thank you so much
thank you oh and the other part is uh if
you want we can I think that um any sort
of advertising and education campaign is
already covered in the educational
language in here but I'll take a look at
that okay great so in terms of the
subcommittee do you have a preference
between Monday and Tuesday morning or
Tuesday afternoon um I'm currently open
as to that I don't know when my other
pending bills are scheduled but I'll
figure that out okay okay thank
you okay okay great thank you and thank
you all for coming to visit us uh for
the committee um so uh tomorrow tomorrow
we have our last three bills for our
public
hearing and I know how much you all love
the public hearing process but time to
move on to the next
stage um so uh terms of next week I will
schedule
subcommittees um and obviously the
liquor subcommittee will be meeting so
I'll start scheduling some of the other
liquor bills um and then we have of
course we have the business is got the
Lion Share of the bills and and and then
insurance does have something we'll be
hearing the insurance uh tomorrow and we
did hear Insurance already um so but
just so everybody knows going forward um
that keeps us busy for next week and if
I look at my calendar properly here um
and then the following week will be uh
subcomittees and uh right well so next
we're going to do we have the Tuesday
Wednesday will exact um so we'll have
I'll try to put in bills for
Tuesday that are look like they're easy
then we could exec them on the 14th
along with this one so it doesn't look
like we're only around executing one
bill um session on the 15th the
following days the 20th and 21st we'll
probably do the same similar situation
and then we have vacation week and yes I
will be out of the country so do not
think you're going to say say anything
to me while I'm away in the Caribbean
and um and then uh come back to to
March and uh which will then
um uh we have according to
what according to I yeah there's always
a question whether and and it's it's
unfortunate I can't tell you the answer
whether we would get a a second
committee
bill um normally historically we never
have gotten a second committee Bill
until Terry narelli started doing it and
Bill oine did so we have had in the past
we have had second committees but not
withstanding that means um we have all
the way to the end of March so we have a
whole month to sub and exact everything
and then the last day to get everything
out uh is March 28th so we're doing good
um I might be tempted to I don't know
change our schedule and only meet on
Tuesday rather than Tuesday Wednesday in
in the session Thursdays but we'll see
how well we we we do um the the the same
problem still occurs that on Tuesdays
we're we're in a committee room we never
know but isn't this cozy being in this
room here like I just this is just I
know 30 some years this is the way
commerce was always for
me you think it's too close no I'm
confused when I leave this room which
way to go oh because we're oh right well
but imagine you know I want to go see
Carrie oh right well it's just I know
cross the down the hall but in terms of
um so in terms of scheduling it will be
determined where how how well we do with
the other subcommittees I think most of
the bills are pretty straightforward in
terms of what we want to do with them
but uh a fair amount of them do need
amendments if we're going to going to
pass them and uh we'll we'll get through
that in the next couple weeks and and we
don't have to there's no pressure um uh
uh because tomorrow we'll have um 10 out
of the 11 bills that we had to get out
of
committee any questions from the commity
members
any comments about what days of the week
you would like to
meet yeah I just have a preference
because I stay over for me it would be
nice to have it Wednesday Thursday
Wednesday Thursday
okay yeah yeah yeah the problem is they
they always make my Chairman's meeting
on Tuesday morning so you can zoom can't
zoom you can't zoom a Chairman's meeting
no well we Zoom all the time not that
was the old days you know so um if we
can that would be awesome okay okay
otherwise my cat's gonna be on the
screen yeah d d
bring I don't know only if it's a
comfort
[Laughter]
kitten so so I
uh